luxembourg is an outside country you  have loads of possibilities to walk to  hike to cycle you can leave your door  open nobody would ever would ever come  in it's as international as london might  be as brussels might be as berries  this is absolute nonsense so in the core  team  we are 27 members 18 of them are women  our team leader is a woman the team  leader before has been a woman  [Music]  i would encourage people first of all to  come to work for europe because europe  is the future it's a project of peace  and if you have specific skills that  help the european parliament to become a  more collaborative organization  yes please do so